hey cinemasins fans as you may have
noticed we're taking a little breather
from the two sins videos a week
scheduled during the month of September
we're still releasing sins videos every
Tuesday but we'll be back to the to a
week scheduled in October that said we
wouldn't just leave you guys hanging
completely one of our editors has put
together this video to hold you over if
you want to see more videos like it he's
made a whole channel where you can find
edits of your favorite films and drink
there is a high chance you have probably
seen one of his videos before such as if
frozen was a horror film or Batman V
Superman retro style if you enjoy the
video and you want to see more you can
click the link in the description or at
the end of the video
order now you get the camera you get the
printer 4x optical zoom Schneider lens
are you in need of any assistance today
sir the following explorers will
graduate to senior explorers for
assisting the elderly
excuse me fugly old man coming through
I'm here for him all units all units
oopss
do you have children detective you can
have Alzheimer's ability
sweet oh no none of your friends here
you shall find at this very dangerous
place
once in there's no way out click here to
subscribe to cinemas for more crazy film
edits like this believe me you are going
to be surprised with the ideas he comes
up with they glamorize gangs and drugs
our art is a reflection of our reality I
like it does hit girls did you know an
utterly insane
oh what a day what a lovely day
Ben Kenobi fathers like auto station
plans are not aboard this ship
when amis alive this is the kind of
arithmetic I like
and now pronounce you teddy bear and
wife may kiss the bear so I got some big
news this means something all some
people have it's all that gives them
hope